- Snapchat Discover?
I don't know what that is.
- Can only look at it once, right?
- From what I understand,
it's an app that you can put on your phone
and you can send it,
messages, to other people.
- So it connects the whole world.
- But I really don't know Snapchat, so,
I'm here to learn.
(whooshing)
(creak)
- It's gonna take five quick photos.
So make as many--
- Goofy faces?
- faces as you can.
Ready?
- One, two,
cool.
And so this'll be (laughs),
oh it's not done yet.
- Perfect!
And then now that's what they see.
Do you like it?
- No, I look like a psycho.
- Do you know what a dick pic is?
- No, I don't.
- A dick pic is,
I'm like turning red.
- You can't just like do
a plain selfie usually.
You wanna like, you know,
make it cool, add filters.
Do you have filters?
- I don't know about filters.
- OK, so what will that
do if I move that up?
Or press the T.
- That'll just format
the text so it's nicer.
- When I press the T it
formats the text, like?
- And when you're traveling
you wanna like get
as many geotags as you can.
- What's a geotag?
- OK.
- So, if you press on the
text again right here--
- OK.
- and you press these colors,
you can change your text color.
- Oh, I like that.
- It's purple!
- Oh, geography tag?
- [Voiceover] Oh, but make
sure it's not 10 seconds,
'cause that's annoying.
- I do seven.
- I say 10.
We're older people and
our eyes have to adjust
and sometimes it takes a little longer.
- OK.
- So now, so now we'll draw on that.
Draw on top of it?
- Mm hm.
- And then you can also add emojis.
- [Voiceover] Oh, you could
really have fun with that.
- [Voiceover] Right!
- I mean, you could write
whatever you wanted to on that.
- Mm hm.
- This is one of the most
fun things about Snapchat,
are the face filters.
So what you do is you do that,
and then you press down on your face,
and it's gonna make that like ding,
and you can choose all
these different filters.
- [Voiceover] Open your mouth.
(laughing)
- It's like taffy
- Hoo. Nice.
That's if I,
Hoo. Yikes.
(deep breathing)
Yikes.
- OK.
So now you just talk and
it's supposed to be funny.
- Oh it, it worked with the face swap!
(laughing)
- [Voiceover] Are these things that you
would wanna use in real life?
- No.
Well, I have to say, I
really am very attractive.
Snapchat really has so
much more application.
I thought it was just you
snapped on that little
funny-looking man and you saw a picture.
- Basically getting your image
out really quick, (snapping)
and getting that
information out to the world
in terms of what you wanna say.
(whooshing)
(creak)